this is a second thought video made
possible by Skillshare who kindly chose
to sponsor this episode or was it
predetermined either way be one of the
first 1,000 people to sign up for
Skillshare using the link below and get
your first two months for just 99 cents
we humans are an interesting species
capable of understanding incredibly
complex ideas about the laws of the
universe yet somehow thinking we operate
outside those laws we're talking as you
probably already gathered about the
notion of free will the idea that I can
do something simply because I want to do
it it makes sense on the surface I
certainly feel like I made the decision
to sleep in this morning but is that
really the case there are a few
different schools of thought we'll start
with what's called libertarian free will
libertarians not to be confused with
political libertarians believe that free
will is incompatible with a
deterministic universe and that agents
have free will therefore determinism the
idea that everything has a past cause
must be false this idea is pretty
appealing to most people because we like
to imagine that everything we do is a
conscious decision that we make go to
class you made that decision skip class
also your decision every action you take
is an action initiated by you and your
conscious brain decided upon out of many
possible options it makes sense right at
any moment you could choose to throw
your phone across the room or raise your
hands in the air or perform any other
action available to you that idea of
having a choice is critical to both
libertarian free will and determinism
this is the part where I make a joke
about both political libertarianism and
libertarian free will not being grounded
in reality not really just kidding at
least about politics because while many
of us would probably say we feel free to
make whatever decisions we choose we
would also probably agree that
everything that happens in the natural
world has a cause and effect if you saw
football flying through the air you
would assume it had been thrown or
kicked this is the underlying belief in
the school of thought known as
determinism the idea that everything
that happens has been caused by past
events making any other option
impossible in other words there is no
choice in the matter if you held a gun
to my head and told me to do something
would you consider my action to be made
freely probably not the gun in this
analogy can be anything past experiences
your genetics a phobia
social norms or any combination of
factors leading you to choose your
action or rather take that action since
it wouldn't really be a free choice and
that's where we run into our problem we
can't really hold both of these beliefs
at the same time or can we this is where
a third school of thought comes in
compatibilism is the idea that free will
and determinism are not mutually
exclusive and defines free will as a
freedom to act according to your own
motives without arbitrary interference
from others one example of this is in
courts of law when a judge has to make a
decision about whether an individual
acted of their own free will under a
specific set of circumstances it's
assumed that the person on trial could
have acted differently than they did
which is why they're on trial in the
first place the basic idea of
compatibilism is that a person may be
free to act according to their own
motives but those motives are determined
one famous quote claims man can do what
he wills but he cannot will what he
wills this is evidenced by an experiment
by Benjamin Libet in which he hooked up
subjects to an EEG and asked them to
perform a simple action like pushing a
button as soon as they were aware of the
wish or urged to act the results showed
that there was always a period of time
preceding the subjects conscious
decision to act that indicated the brain
had already made an unconscious decision
as of 2008 further studies had shown
that the upcoming outcome of such a test
could be found in brain activity up to 7
seconds before the subject was aware of
a conscious urge to perform the action
but let's go back to the court of law if
we truly are subject to these
unconscious pre decisions can we be held
morally responsible for our actions one
prime example of this dilemma can be
found in the case of Charles Whitman a
sniper who killed 16 people and wounded
31 others from the top of a tower at the
University of Texas in Austin
Whitman left a note saying he didn't
understand why he was committing these
horrible crimes and to perform an
autopsy to figure out what was wrong
with him after he died
sure enough the autopsy revealed a tumor
that many suspected to have pressed
against the portion of his brain that
controlled his emotions and led to his
violent actions in this case Whitman was
not forced by any other person to commit
violent crimes but neither was he truly
acting of his own unimpaired volition he
could not will what he willed what do we
do with cases like this extreme medical
cases aside most compatibilist suggest
that we should be able to
take credit for our good actions and
blame for our bad ones as long as a
person is free from outside coercion
they have freedom of action the highest
degree of free will conceivable under
compatibilism whether we are aware of it
or not we are all subject to these
unconscious drivers silently guiding us
to take the path we choose if you wake
up and decide you're going to have ice
cream for breakfast that idea didn't
just come out of nowhere your brain had
made that decision long before you were
aware of it so what do we do if we're
all just biological robots driven by
unknown causes
what does that mean for Humanity maybe
nothing the world will continue as it
always has people making decisions and
taking actions that they feel are their
own ideas and maybe that's all we need
to know what do you think are we all
just biological cogs in a deterministic
machine or do we have some semblance of
control over our motives and actions or
is all of this just nonsense and doesn't
matter at all and everything is
pointless
whatever your thoughts on the matter you
should choose to visit Skillshare and
start learning an awesome new skill to
take your mind off the meaningless void
of existence Skillshare is an online
learning community for creators
featuring over 17,000 classes and
graphic design animation photography and
more that could help you learn a new
skill or even start a YouTube channel
like I did a premium membership from
Skillshare is more affordable than most
other online learning platforms and
gives you unlimited access to amazing
classes from experts working in their
fields so you can improve your skills
unlock new opportunities and do the work
you love as a special offer for second
thought fans you can get your first two
months for just 99 cents when you sign
up using the link below to support
second thought and start learning
amazing new skills be sure to visit
Skillshare today if you enjoyed this
video make sure to subscribe and click
the little bell to be notified every
time a new second thought video is
released while you're here check out
these playlists of other great content
and if you really want to support the
channel and get a behind-the-scenes look
at second thought check out our patreon
page thanks for watching and we'll see
you next week